♪
THE FOLLOWED STILL COMING IN
FAST AND FURIOUS OVER THE FBI'S
RAID ON FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
MAR-A-LAGO REAL ESTATE.
REPUBLICANS DEMANDING ANSWERS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE DOJ
AS WE LEARN BRAND-NEW DETAILS.
HERE THEY ARE.
THE FBI REPORTEDLY SEARCH
THROUGH THE FORMER FIRST LADY
LINNEA TRUMP'S WARDROBE AND
SPENT HOURS AND TRUMPS PRIVATE
HOURS TEASING ABOUT A DOZEN
BOXES ON MONDAY BUT SOME OF THE
MATERIALS RECOVERED FROM EARLIER
THIS YEAR INCLUDING LETTERS FROM
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA AS WELL
AS A COCKTAIL NAPKIN AND A
BIRTHDAY DINNER MENU.
AN ATTORNEY FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TELLING JESSE, OUR OWN
JESSE WATTERS, THAT THE FBI
WOULD NOT LET TRUMPS LEGAL TEAM
KEEP A COPY OF THE PRESENTED
SEARCH WARRANT.
>> OUR COUNTRY SHOULD BE
TERRIFIED.
I'M TERRIFIED, I CAN TELL YOU HE
WAS NOT ONLY WORKING WITH THEM,
HE WAS COOPERATING PAIR THERE
WAS NOTHING TO HIDE, AND HE WAS
WORKING IN TANDEM AND ALLOWED
THEM INTO MAR-A-LAGO.
THE POINT AS THEY WENT WHEN HE
WAS DEEP IN THERE AND TOLD HIS
ATTORNEYS TO LEAVE.
>> WHY DOESN'T THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY JUST RELEASED A
WARRANT?
THEY WERE PROBABLY HANDED A
WARRANT.
IT'S BECOME MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE ATTORNEYS ON THE GROUND
AS THEY WERE NOT GIVEN THE
WARRANT THAT THEY WERE ALLOWED
TO SEE IT AND THEN TAKEN BACK.
>> FOX BUSINESSES REPORT THE
TRUMP AND HIS LEGAL TEAM WILL
LIKELY SEEK A COURT ORDER TO
FORCE THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO TURN OVER A
PHYSICAL COPY OF THE SEARCH
WARRANT.
THE AFFIDAVIT, AND A COMPLETE
INVENTORY OF WHAT WAS TAKEN IN
THE MAR-A-LAGO RAID.
MEANWHILE THERE IS GROWING
SPECULATION AMONG REPUBLICANS
THAT THE FBI RAID ON MAR-A-LAGO
COULD ACTUALLY ACCELERATE A
TRUMP 2024 RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FIRED UP IS
WHAT HE WAS DENIED.
HE'S NOT DETERRED.
IF ANYTHING IT PAVES THE WAY FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO UNIFY THE PARTY
DO YOU RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> DID I MISS ANYTHING?
>> WELCOME BACK BY THE WAY.
YOU LOOK GREAT.
THE SWELLING IS DOWN, YOU LOOK
TEN YEARS YOUNGER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
>> IT'S WEIRD WHEN YOU GO FOR
ONE OF THOSE PROCEDURES YOU HAVE
THE SOCIALLY DISTANCE FOR TEN
DAYS.
IT'S A WEIRD PANDEMIC THING
THAT'S HAPPENING BUT JESSE, IT'S
A TRUE NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW
BUT WHILE THE SCIENCE DON'T LIKE
SILENCE CONTINUES FROM THE DOJ
ON THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE FBI
THAT IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
PEOPLE ARE SUSPECT ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> BUT.
>> BIDEN RATED TRUMPS HOUSE AND
THEN WENT ON VACATION.
HE TOOK HUNTER AND AIR FORCE ONE
WITH THEM.
IT'S CRAZY.
"NEWSWEEK" REPORTED THEY HAD A
MOLE INSIDE MAR-A-LAGO, WHICH
DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
THEY PUT MOLDS IN THE CAMPAIGN,
BULLET MOLDS ALL OVER THE PLACE
WHERE THEY PROBABLY PUT THEM ALL
OUT FOX.
I DON'T EVEN BELIEVE THERE WAS A
BALL.
THAT IS A JUSTIFICATION TO SAY
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THEY BOUGHT A
SAFE, THAT'S WHY WE WENT IN.
THE ARCHIVIST AT START OF THIS
WHOLE DRAMA, THE SKY IS A TOTAL
WEIRDO.
SO JANUARY 6TH WAS THE WORST DAY
OF HIS LIFE.
HE WASN'T AT THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6TH, THE CAPITAL IS
BLOCKS AWAY.
HE SAID HE SAW ON TELEVISION
TRUMP LEAVING FOR MAR-A-LAGO ON
THE INAUGURATION WITH THE BOX
AND HE SAID WHAT'S IN THAT BOX?
THAT'S WHEN THIS WHOLE THING
STARTED.
NOW OBAMA HAS BOXES OF STUFF IN
CHICAGO, BIDEN HAS STUFF AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE.
REMEMBER YOU CAN'T SEE IT BUT
TRUMPS NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE A
LOVE LETTER FROM A LITTLE ROCKET
MAN.
PROBABLY THE WORST JUDGE IN THE
COUNTRY?
HE REPRESENTED THE PILOT, THE
PILOT THAT THROUGH CHILDREN TO
AN ISLAND TO GET RAPED.
YOU NORMALLY SPEND TIME IN
PRISON BUT FOR SOME REASON THIS
GUY SPENT NO TIME IN PRISON
BECAUSE THIS GUY GOT THEM A
SWEETHEART DEAL.
HE DIDN'T EVEN LEAK INTO RAT OUT
EPSTEIN.
AND IS ALL OVER SOCIAL MEDIA
SAYING I HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP, I
LOVE JILL BIDEN.
THAT'S WHO THEY WENT TO.
JUDICIAL WATCH JUST FILED A FOIA
REQUEST.
THEY HAVE UNTIL MONDAY TO
EXPLAIN THE DOJ WHY THEY DID
THIS AND SHOW THE AFFIDAVIT.
THE SURVEILLANCE VIDEO OF
MAR-A-LAGO EXISTS.
SO I THINK THEY SHOULD REALLY
START TO SHOW THESE GUYS
RUMMAGING THROUGH MELANIA'S
CLOSET.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THE PRESIDENT WENT IN THERE AND
STUFFED THINGS IN HER
UNDERGARMENTS AND SO DOCUMENTS
INSIDE OF HER ADDRESSES SO THEY
COULDN'T SEE IT?
THAT'S CRAZY.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF THEY
PLANTED THE BUGS.
THEY DID BUG THE CAMPAIGN.
THEY FRAUDULENTLY DOCTORED
EVIDENCE TO GET A WARRANT TO
WIRETAP THE CAMPAIGN BUT I WOULD
SWEEP THAT WHOLE ESTATE WITH A
BUG SWEEPER, WHATEVER THOSE
THINGS ARE CALLED.
SO THE AG IS IN HIDING, JILL
BIDEN IS IN HIDING.
AND LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT,
DEMOCRATS ARE SO UPSET ABOUT
BEING HACKED IN ALL OF THE SENSE
OF THE MATERIALS OUT THERE, SO
HILLARY GETS HACKED AND
EVERYBODY HAS BOWED, OBAMA'S
WHITE HOUSE GETS HACKED BY
CHELSEA MANNING, GETS HACKED BY
WHO WAS THE OTHER GUY?
SNOWDEN?
LISA WEEKS THE DOCUMENTS
EVERYWHERE.
JILL BIDEN'S AND LOSES HIS
LAPTOP IT'S ALL OUT THERE.
HIS DAUGHTERS DIARIES OUT THERE.
THAT'S FINE.
DEMOCRATS ARE ELECTORAL
DOCUMENTS ALL OVER THE WORLD
EVERYBODY CAN SEE IT.
BUT TRUMP HAS A LETTER FROM
KIM JONG UN THEY HAVE TO RAID
HIS ESTATE OVER?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
TRUMP SHOULD HAVE WITH
EVERYTHING ON FIRE.
CROOKED BLEACHED EVERYTHING IS
SET I'M GOING TO DESTROY THE
PERSONAL STUFF, HERE'S THE
WORK-RELATED OFF.
WHY DIDN'T TRUMP YOU THAT?
>> DO YOU GET THE SENSE
DEMOCRATS ARE FEELING SOME
PRESSURE FROM THE FBI OR DOJ TO
AT LEAST SAY SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED?
>> I'M GLAD WE ARE BACK TO USING
HILLARY CLINTON'S LEGAL BIRTH
NAME.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THERE IS DEFINITELY SOME
PRESSURE OUT THERE, ANDREW CUOMO
CAME OUT AND SAID YESTERDAY WE
HAVE TO HEAR ABOUT THIS.
HE'S NOT IN GOOD STEAD WITH THE
PARTY BUT IS A PROMINENT
DEMOCRAT.
PEOPLE GENERALLY WANT ANSWERS.
EVERYBODY IS UNIFIED IN THE
REASON THEY WANT THOSE ANSWERS
IS DIFFERENT AND DEMOCRATS ARE
CERTAINLY LOOKING AT THIS AND
HOW IT'S BEEN PRETRADE IN TERMS
OF PUNDITRY AND THE TYPES OF
ARTICLES WRITTEN ABOUT THIS IN
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN A
FILM LIKE MADE.
OUR HEADS ARE SPENDING IS THE
NUMBER OF MID'S TRUTHS AND
ASSUMPTIONS BEING PROTECTED ALL
OVER TELEVISION.
FROM THE IDEA THERE WAS EVIDENCE
THAT WAS PLANTED.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOW AMPLIFYING
THAT.
ERIC TRUMP WENT ON TV AND SAID
THAT BIDEN SIGNED OFF ON THIS.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS JUST TITLE
TELLING HIM HOW HIS FATHER USED
TO DO THINGS BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION --
>> BECAUSE BIDEN ALWAYS TELLS
THE TRUTH LIKE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
MY SON WAS DOING WITH THE
CHINESE.
DO YOU BELIEVE HIM WHEN HE SAYS
HE DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING?
HE ALSO SAYS HE DOESN'T --
>> I CAN GIVE IT UP BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO WASTE TIME THAT
BIDEN SOBBED AROUND AND TO TAKE,
MERRICK GARLAND, THIS IS WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING NOW.
>> BUT SHOULD HE KNOW?
IS THE PRESIDENT HE'S IN CHARGE.
SPEAK.
>> THE DOJ IS SUPPOSED TO
FUNCTION SEPARATELY.
THIS JUDGE BY THE WAY, WHO
DONATED TO PRESIDENT OBAMA
ENTERED JOB BUSH, NOW HE HAS TO
HAVE HIS INFORMATION SCRUBBED
FROM THE INTERNET, HE AND HIS
FAMILY HAVE BEEN THREATENED.
>> TELL THAT TO THE
SUPREME COURT --
>> AS A JUDGE I'M SHOCKED.
A LOT HERE ABOUT AT THIS TABLE
IS THAT IT IS ONLY DEMOCRATS
THAT ARE CRAZY AND UNHINGED
VIOLENT TYPES.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT'S HAPPENED
IN A DAY, THAT THIS MAN HAS TO
GO INTO HIDING.
WE HEARD ALSO FROM THE ATTORNEY
WHO APPEARED ON YOUR SHOW WHO
SAID NONE OF TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS
WERE ALLOWED TO BE PRESENT.
LINDSEY HALLIGAN FROM TRUMP'S
TEAM WAS PRESENT DURING THE
MULTIHOUR SEARCH.
THAT INFORMATION IS DANGEROUS
HERE.
IF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN -- I
SHOULDN'T SAY CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE
IF THE TRUMP GROUP, TEAM HAS THE
WARRANT OR ANY INFORMATION OF
WHAT THEY SEE THEY SHOULD REALLY
SAID.
THE BURDEN IS NOT ON THE DOJ.
IS GOING TO SAY THEY PLANTED
SOMETHING, PROVE IT.
WHOSE BURDEN IS AT?
>> WHOSE BURDEN IS THAT?
WHO DRAFTED IT?
BUT ME BACK UP FOR A SECOND.
HIS WHOLE DEFENSE WAS TELL US
WHAT WAS IN THE WARRANT, TELL US
WHAT WAS IN THE WARRANT FOR THAT
WAS THE DEFENSE FURTHER
DEMOCRATS.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T GET A COPY
OF THAT WARRANT, NEITHER DID
ANYBODY ON THE TEAM.
I SPOKE TO ERIC TRUMP 10 MINUTES
BEFORE THIS SHOW, THEY WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO GET A COPY OF THE
WARRANT.
THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
ANY OF THE ATTORNEYS ON SCENE
THERE WHILE THE FBI --
>> WHAT ABOUT LINDSAY HALLIGAN?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE "NEWSWEEK,"
BUT LET ME MAKE MY POINT HERE.
I WAS A JUDGE, YOU DECIDE A
WARRANT BASED UPON THE
APPLICATION AND THE AFFIDAVIT.
WE KNOW THE FBI HAS NO
CREDIBILITY BECAUSE THE FBI PUT
IN AFFIDAVITS BEFORE PFIZER
JUDGES REGARDING NATIONAL
SECURITY DATA WERE BASED ON LIES
AND TRUMP HATERS WHO WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
WALKED.
THAT SAME PROOF THAT CALLED US
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS, WHO THEN
LIED ABOUT MAKING SURE
DONALD TRUMP WOULDN'T BE
PRESIDENT, WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THEM?
CHRISTOPHER WRAY IS A TRUMP
APPOINTEE.
>> IS MUCH A PART OF THE
DEEP STATE AS THE REST OF THEM?
>> WHERE IS THAT COMING FROM?
>> CHRISTOPHER RAY WAS CALLED TO
ANSWER BEFORE CONGRESS, HE
COULDN'T ANSWER ANYTHING TWO
WEEKS AGO ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN CONGRESS IN TERMS OF WHAT
HE'S DOING WITH THE FBI, HOW
HE'S PUNISHED ANY OF THE PEOPLE
WHETHER IT WAS MAKEDA, STRUCK,
OR THE REST OF THEM.
HE DID NOTHING, ZERO, ZILCH,
ALL RIGHT?
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THIS
WARRANT.
THEY CAN PUT ANYTHING THEY WANT
IN THE WARRANT.
IT'S THE EXECUTION OF THE
WARRANT THAT IS FILED WITH THE
COURT THAT CONTAINS WHAT THEY'VE
GOT.
NOW HOW DO THEY TAKE THOSE
BOXES?
IN JUDICIOUSLY WAS THE WORD THAT
WAS USED.
THAT MEANS THEY TOOK BOXES, THEY
DID NO INVENTORY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS IN THE
BOX.
THEY SET IT UP SO THEY CAN SAY
ANYTHING WAS IN THE BOX.
TO GO THROUGH MILLENNIA TRUMP'S
CLOTHES IS AND HOW TO READ.
THIS EFFORT TO INTIMIDATE THE
TRUMP AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
TRUMPS ARE NOT IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY CAN DENY ANYTHING.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY HERE,
WHAT WE'VE GOT IS A CORRUPT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, A CORRUPT
FBI BASED UPON WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
THEY'VE GONE AFTER DONALD TRUMP
FOR SEVEN YEARS, THEY WILL NOT
STOP AT THE FBI, THE DOJ, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WANT HIM ON
ANYTHING.
I'M TELLING YOU SURE AS I AM
SITTING HERE THE GUYS GOING TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT NOW BECAUSE
THEY PUSHED HIS BUTTONS.
>> HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
MANAGING THIS SLOT.
I'M OVER TIME BUT I WANT TO GIVE
YOU TIME TO EITHER MAKE FUN OF
ME OR MAKE A COMMENT.
>> MAKE COMMENTS, I HAVE TO
ADDRESS JESSICA'S POINT ABOUT
THE THREATS TO THE JUDGE.
I THINK IS LEGITIMATE AS THOSE
THREATS MIGHT BE, YOU ARE SEEING
THE PIVOT FROM IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE RAID HE COMMITS THE POUNCING
OF THE RIGHT.
THIS ALWAYS HAPPENS WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENS, WHILE THE
RIGHT IS NOT POUNCING AND THAT'S
THEIR OF PIVOTING AWAY FROM THE
ACTUAL INJUSTICE.
I DO THINK JESSE HAS A RIGHT TO
BE SKEPTICAL OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
ALL OF THE PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
TRUMP WAS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT,
NUMBER TWO HE WAS THE NEXT
HITLER, RIGHT?
SO IF YOU DIDN'T WANT TO TRY TO
GET THEM OFF THE POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE, YOU'RE KIND OF A
COWARD, RIGHT?
YOU ARE COMPLICIT.
SO THE THING IS THEY CAN'T ARGUE
THAT HE'S EVIL AND THEN DO
NOTHING ABOUT IT, INCLUDING GO
ABOVE THE LAW.
IF I FELT THAT THERE WAS
SOMEBODY THAT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT WHO WAS HITLER I WOULD
BREAK THE LAW.
IF I COULD GO BACK IN TIME AND
KILL HITLER THAT'S ALWAYS THE
QUESTION, YOU WOULD DO IT.
YOU CAN'T SAY THIS ABOUT TRUMP
AND THEN SAY YOU ARE GOING TO BE
BELOW THE LAW.
WE ALSO WENT THROUGH MILANI HAS
CLOSET WHICH -- IMAGINE IF THEY
DID THAT WITH HILLARY.
THEY WON'T FIND ONE PANT SUIT
AND A SERVER.
THEY WENT INTO DR. JOSEPH CLOSET
THEY FIND AN ONLINE DEGREE AND
30 CASES OF PRIVATE GENDERED IF
THEY WANTED TO JOE'S CLOSET THEY
WOULD FIND ROBERT BYRD.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT WHATEVER YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT IT, IT GOES
BACK TO THE SIMPLICITY THAT A
LOT OF THE THINGS THAT TRUMP DID
IT NEVER WAS BY THE RULES.
IT DIDN'T REALLY -- HE WAS
OUTSIDE THAT WORLD.
HE TOOK THIS STUFF HOME.
LIKE I DON'T CARE, I'VE GOT SOME
NAPKINS AND I GOT A SIGNED
PHOTO, I GOT SOME STUFF FROM
JESSE.
THEN IT'S LIKE THEY WANT IT BACK
THEN IT'S LIKE IT'S MY STUFF.
I CONCEDE THAT THAT IS HOW HE
LOOKS AT IT.
BUT THE MOTIVES TO GO AFTER HIM
MAKE ME THINK THEY DO WANT TRUMP
TO RUN.
THIS IS VERY REMINISCENT OF
2015.
EGG THE GUY ON, TALK ABOUT HIM
AS A JOKE AND A THREAT, WATCH
THE RATINGS EXPLODE.
SUDDENLY HE'S ON A MORNING SHOW
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
BASICALLY JEFF ZUCKER IS SUCKING
ON HIS TOES, THEN THEY ARE
DROOLING OVER THE GUY IN WHAT
HAPPENED, THEY ELECTED THEM.
NOW THEY TRUMP DERANGEMENT IS
CREATING IN VITRO AND THEY ARE
DOOMED TO REPEAT IT AGAIN.
REMEMBER THIS AT THIS LAST NIGHT
ON MY SHOW.
ALL IT TOOK WAS A JOKE AT THE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER TO GET
TRUMP TO RUN.
WHAT HE THINK THIS IS GOING TO
DO?
NOT ONLY IS HE GOING TO RUN,
HE'S GOING TO UNITE EVERYBODY
BEHIND THEM.
YOU JUST DID SOMETHING SO
INCREDIBLY VISUAL, YOU RAIDED
HIS HOUSE.
LASTLY, THEY GOT THE BALL
ROLLING ON RETRIBUTION.
NOW WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU SEE COLBERT LAUGHING ABOUT
THIS?
THIS IS GOING TO BE FUNNY WHEN
THE REPUBLICAN IS IN THERE AND
DECIDES TO GO AFTER JOE BIDEN
BEAUTIES BEEN IN POLITICS FOR 50
YEARS.
GOD KNOWS THE AMOUNT OF SHADY
DEALINGS GOING ON IN HIS LIFE.
AS A SOPRANOS WITH A SEX
ADDICTION.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD PATTERN TO
START TO GO AFTER THE PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT.
BUT NOW ALL BETS ARE OFF.
>> COULDN'T BE HE ACTUALLY JUST
DID SOMETHING REALLY BAD THAT HE
SHOULD NEVER HAVE DONE IT?
BECAUSE HE WITH THEM?
>> NO HE DIDN'T.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT,
BUT I WON'T, KEEP IT.
IT'S JUST THE SANDY BERGER THING
REALLY PISSES ME OFF WHEN THEY
TRIED TO HIDE THE FACT THAT THE
CLINTON DID